is it possible for someone who has a
normal income to do this diet meat is
expensive is it not and what about
travel okay multi-part question so it's
totally possible to do this on a very
low budget it can be way cheaper than
eating the standard American diet what
you want to do is you want to go to a
butcher or go to your meat department
and just buy the cheap Cuts doesn't
matter what they are buy the cheap Cuts
you could survive off of tongue if you
needed to that's dirt cheap and if you
go to my handy website liondiet.com
there is a recipe for crunchy things and
you can literally make the most garbage
cuts into delicious crispy things by
adding fat so you can buy fat from a
butcher fat is really cheap they
commonly cut fat off of cuts and throw
it away so make friends with a butcher
buy fat buy the cheap Cuts you can do a
heart too you can do organs I know I
just talked down to organs but like
heart is it's a it's a muscle and tongue
is a muscle so that's still muscle meat
basically get the cheap Cuts add fat get
a pressure cooker and an air fryer and
your set okay and the pressure cooker
and air fryer are an upfront expense at
the beginning of the diet they will save
you so much time and they'll make your
food so good it's really worth investing
into them but you don't have to have a
bunch of money to do this diet it can be
very cheap and it makes you healthier
you should do it especially if you're
sick travel okay because I have
histamine intolerance and I can't eat
aged meat travel's a bit tricky because
going out to restaurants and eating
steak isn't an option because steak is
always aged at restaurants so I can
either go out and eat lamb that's
insanely expensive now generally
speaking I literally take an air fryer
ninja XXL sponsor me put it in a
suitcase put it under the plane and air
Fry at the Airbnb that's usually what I
do it's not super glamorous I've also
been known with my husband to just pack
a bunch of frozen meat in a suitcase and
bring it with me with my air fryer
you're like what that's not fun yeah but
you know what's less fun having an
autoimmune disorder and being crazy
that's way less fun plus it's kind of
hilarious is to pack a suitcase full of
meat with an air fryer and then bring it
to an Airbnb you can also do long-term
hotels so if you're to stay somewhere
for a week then there are hotels that
have kitchens in them also you don't
really need a kitchen with an air fryer
you could kind of stay in a hotel and
use an air fryer you have to be a little
sneaky because it can get kind of smoky
so it's better to get a hotel where you
can cook outside of the room with a
little patio Hotel patio air fryer
suitcase full of meat girls got to do
what a girl's got to do to not have
arthritis
foreign
[Music]